hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now for
the first time in a while I'm going to
be starting off the episode directly by
commemorating the people who commented
in the last video and the first one up
is Diego m'appelle who said when will he
meet the ghost Leviathan the Lost River
which I don't know if the ghost
Leviathan is there yet but I'm
officially in the experimental build
once again and even though big box
berries a little damage to ignore that
everything's fine I'm not worried about
it next up is Alex H who said is it me
or does anyone else count how many
seconds before Marc freaks out after
saying okay everything seems to be fine
and hey that's not my fault that the
world decides to [ __ ] me over as soon as
I say those words as if that's alien
code to come attack me not my fault
then there's Carson bland who said
silent mode doesn't work if you keep
screaming stop attacking me and that
made me realize that it probably from
the outside all the fish are hearing
this muffled Wow like coming from this
weird giant yellow boat that's just
trying to sneak along at a snail's pace
so entirely that's all my fault and I'm
sorry about that but now that we're back
in the experimental build there's
something very very special waiting for
us down in the depths back in the Lost
River or not even in the Lost River the
active lava zone which I am eventually
going back down to but before I do that
before I do that I have to number one go
to the island at full speed and then I
have to get arbol melons which I should
have had this whole time I don't know
why I've been choking down 1700 of these
goddamn lantern fruit when I could have
just been eating marble melons
I'm and I would have been totally fine
and then I would have more than one
planter and I wouldn't have just been
eating until my stomach explodes if I
got just froth out of my belly all over
my inside of my big box berry if that
sentence made sense in any other world
in any other context I'd be amazed but
that is the truth of my situation so I'm
gonna go real quick to the island I'm
gonna grab that stuff I'll I'll be right
back I'm gonna plum about the beach
myself aren't I
Oh Lily and then I'm going to cycle back
because there's only one other upgrade
that I want to make for my big box berry
and that is the sonar upgrade and to do
that I need polyaniline
and to make polyaniline I need
hydrochloric acid and to do that I need
to go get some deep mushrooms because
you can only make hydrochloric acid out
of certain acid mushrooms not these guys
you gotta get the deep fruits you have
to have them for that I didn't even know
about hydrochloric acid I didn't even
know what polyaniline
was I don't even think I've ever made
them but now I will so I'm gonna be
right back as soon as I find me a garble
melon oh that is that that that that's
weird
why are you guys just floating on the
surface like that I'm a little I'm more
than a little bit perturbed by that
usually they're moving or they're like
breaching or or something or other but
they're just oh my god it's a bigger pot
than I thought it was gonna be okay all
right you carry on I gotta get to the
island oh that is majestic I know I
gotta eat that's why I'm going to get
old Marvel Ellen are you bothered yeah
seducing them with my massive mirrors oh
oh why do we have those sharks around
here that's there they're not suppose
they're about to get rammed that's what
they're about to get what the hell is
that in it I don't know what's going on
these [ __ ] are gonna get ran hey oh
oh no I'm so sorry
oh [ __ ] you dude oh man that hurt woman
look then it hurt them [ __ ] but the
can't catch me chubowski
not when I pull up now when I walk oh my
god
fire detected wow that's not what I
meant that's not what I wanted I didn't
want that oh I didn't want that okay
where are we going
where's the fire where's the fire I hear
a fire ty get down to the lower deck
please Oh Paul God Wow Luce
oh good ears oh goody risky oh good ear
ski
okay what else we got okay cue the job
status [ __ ] Oh what the hell is that
alrighty then well we got our first fire
and we're not doing good okay
note to self body slamming the local
fauna is not a good idea and not a good
preventative for damage oh my god okay
oh no oh that's my laser I don't need
that I need the where's where's my
where's my repair tool did did I drop it
what is the [ __ ] holes widen the [ __ ] my
dicks
and Addison yeah I'm aware of that thank
you but what happened to my goddamn
doodled anger what happened oh what
happened to my repair jewel what is cave
sulfur I don't know what cave sulfur is
I'm going to be very pissed thank the
Lord
I almost shat my britches there okay all
right then let me put my fire
extinguisher back too because well I
have a funny feeling I'm gonna need it
again soon okay look all right good
hopefully that refills all right let me
go repair sorry about this a little bit
of a crisis up which seems to get in my
way
when you bodyslam the opposition now I'd
like to think that body slams are the
solution to all of life's problems got
an angry neighbor just body slam them
into submission to hook misbehaving just
bodies left that [ __ ]
grandma acting up this body slammer you
never should have alright I think that's
most of it if not all of it alright good
Al we're back on track
thank you oh we got some damage up there
I'll get that when I get over to the
place oh no it's about to be dark maybe
I should actually use this bed that I
built for such a person that I need to
do that oh it's so pretty
I sometimes forget how beautiful that is
over there god that's a gorgeous sunset
that's something to be commemorated by
me screaming at the top of my lungs
about how terrifying every begins ha ha
ha where is my goddamn night and I gotta
get this hey you want to go bro
you want to go I've sliced up worse than
you and my day
are you dead now are you dead who's
skittering out there grab these bad boys
Hey oh you're dead
hi I got the marble darlings I got the
Malone's my Ghanim I could have at any
time come back and got these but then I
did
cuz I'm dumb I'll be right back once I
plant these bad boys inside my boat
hopefully I can plant these bad boys
inside my boat I think I can therefore I
will oh those key okay and then what
these bad boys point and then point and
then I want that small I want I want big
meanie marble melons yeah hell yeah and
I don't know why I don't know why
there's Chinese potatoes on here but I'm
gonna munch and munch yes yes I've got
malone's hell yeah finally what if it'd
taken me so long to do this I'm just a
big dumb goof but I'm gonna need more
more pots eventually for all of them
alone because the lantern fruit that'll
make a lot of stuff in a small area but
for the Malone
amah need way more so what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to make individual small
plans then I'm gonna have the marbled
melons all lining the walls in here
because I am a bad ass long Punk okay so
I'm gonna have marble Malone's over
there and that'll be better for me yeah
yeah reclaimed water bokya tranfered
swig a victory piss hell yeah okay so
now that we got that out of the way that
was a minor objective on this whole
endeavor now comes the real heart of the
matter getting this sonar upgrade which
is something that I'm very keen on
getting so what I got to do is I got a
dive dive dive down
yes you born hopefully not too loudly
but I'm gonna go loud me anyway because
I'm a badass and I don't care I got a
shield as long as I grab a shield I
think I'll be okay which is a goddamn
lie tell myself to go to sleep at night
but down there deep in the depths down
here somewhere Hills the deep truths not
in this area not necessarily in this
area but in the areas below this high
warp II whoo
he has gone warps - not in my areas over
there but down here in the sea tread
errs path I think it's the closest place
to be able to get deep troops
I could also go down into the Lost River
and there would be tons of up down there
and I probably could do that but I'm I
don't I don't want to do that that's the
key I don't want to go there so I'll be
right back once I get to those deep
truth here it is hi
oh you freakish bastards oh you freaky
weirdos
all right don't mind me hey what's up
how's it doing okay I'm just gonna go
into your tunnel here this seems to be
the place I mean the choir is screaming
all its markiplier not him again
but uh alas yes it is me unfortunately
here to ruin everything
oh hi see threader's god I've never
actually written the entirety of the see
treasures past so I didn't actually know
the scope of it like its legit huge like
geez ah so crazy all right but I think
in here and I am now going in the cave I
am in the cave now yes that's what I'm
looking for right down there the deep
tree
so I'm gonna go out and give them but
some something to warn you guys about
these deep shrooms
apparently harvesting them is tricky
because they can damage you I mean they
are a very very potent acid at least
that's what I've been told so I'm going
to collect what I can in whatever way I
can
scoop deep huh huh that's what it did
Oh wowie ah but that's how you get deep
room Spore that's interesting so if you
slice up you get deep room
truce or but it hurts like a
son-of-a-bitch because you just spill
acid all over your body so anyway I'm
going to pick up a bunch of these things
because I need to mix them with a very
special element gold and when you mix
them with gold you create polyaniline so
I'm hoping oh god you are you are weird
creatures for being so docile oh I don't
like it okay alright May it feels like
forever since the first time I saw those
things Emeritus weird horrifying
elephant creatures just treading the
bottom of the ocean air real real prime
subjective something I never want to
meet even though they're they're like
totally harmless but let me not totally
harmless nothing here is totally
harmless but there we go hydrochloric
acid Oh needed salt
nobody needed ah but I can make
polyaniline now now I believe I need two
of these if I'm not mistaken I'm going
to need two of these so I need to make I
need to get another salt deposit and I
mean to slap another one of these bad
boys together in the shear and then once
I have a second polyaniline I forget
what the other subject material that I
needed but I don't think it's too
terribly complicated because if I go up
here to the other crafting Bay which
technically speaking
is just a simple thing I need magnetite
and I believe I believe I did gather up
a bunch of magnetite in a previous
episode I think I did
that's aluminum oxide you're a knight oh
did I get magnetite did I do don't know
I don't even know what magnetite looks
like anymore there's kyanite 32 T's
Flutey buddies ah titty widdy's okay
can't believe that eye is still alive in
there we take this out of here cuz this
is let's be there very low chance very
low chance magnetite
I did I have exactly P I have exactly
Hey
okay and then when you put the magnetite
oh [ __ ] dude well god damn it I now have
only seen pictures of crasher nothing
but I now have the lovely sonar upgrade
flappity blue p'tee and there you goofy
so now if I go over here to the main
area right here and I hit good old sonar
oh oh that's so nice that is so nice and
this is like the perfect place for it
because I can actually see where the
flip frickin frackin I'm going oh my god
and I know that probably takes a good
bit of power but you don't understand
how helpful that is because I fly blind
a lot of the time when I'm in this big
ass big-box berry I fly blind this
effect creatures does it ma'am
nah unfortunately you don't hit
creatures but that's fine oh but that is
so cool all you guys I am oh that's so
cool I can see I can flip Nick and see
now and it doesn't take that much power
so I got that I got the shield
I am freaking good to go
I am G to G oh man this is so cool I'll
ring the bell ping pong her like that
SCP Bell Bing bong bring it on you a
bunch of futures so now the reason I
wanted this is because it's going to
make navigating deep down in the depths
that much easier for me and because of
that I'm able to navigate tighter spaces
see where I need to go see caves when I
need to see caves which isn't always the
case caves like to hide on me they do
they definitely do but now the last step
is to go down into the key and get down
to that lava zone in between now in the
next episode I'm going to do some
farming but I am fully prepared to go
down there and build my base right at
the heart of that castle and hopefully
not die to the sea dragon I've got a
weird idea that uh if I get enough of
those corn shooters maybe I could use
them as like defensive turrets against
the sea dragon but I don't think it's
going to be nearly enough for what I
have in mind so with that being said
thank you everybody so much for watching
look forward to going down into the deep
in the next episode so thanks again let
me know how I'm doing in the comments
below and if you comment well I might
just put you on your locker so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
buh-bye
[Music]